the entire crypto world seems to be
falling apart right now
on November 7th Sam Beekman freed said
his crypto exchange FTX one of the
largest exchanges in the world was quote
fine
the very next day the entire exchange
imploded
people were trying to withdraw their
money from FTX but FTX didn't have
enough money to go around it was a
classic Bank Run and if FTX didn't
somehow get their hands on some
emergency cash to give back to customers
it would collapse so Sam had no choice
but to come crawling to his arch nemesis
a guy named CZ behind the exchange
binance for a bailout for a minute it
looked like binance was gonna save the
day but right before the Clock Struck
midnight binance backed out hinting that
FTX had mishandled customers money and
just like that FTX was screwed with no
Bella and no way for customers to
withdraw their money Sam bakeman Free's
net worth dropped from a staggering 15
billion dollars down 94 to just shy of a
billion dollars in a single day it was
the biggest free-fall in billionaire
history just three days later FTX filed
for bankruptcy it was the most
catastrophic collapse in the history of
crypto
and just like how Lehman Brothers
collapse sparked the 2008 financial
crisis FTX might just take the entire
crypto World down with it this is a
story of money power and Cutthroat
ruthless Financial Warfare and it's all
centered around a rivalry between two of
the world's biggest crypto billionaires
Sam bankman freed up FTX and chungpung
Zhao or CZ of binance binance is the
Behemoth in the crypto World in 2021 it
recorded more than 7 trillion dollars in
trading volume that's more than half of
all crypto traded that year making CZ
the most powerful and influential man in
all of crypto FTX on the other hand was
one of the fastest growing crypto
exchanges in the world between 2020 and
2021 ftx's Revenue increased by more
than a thousand percent but in cz's eyes
sand bakeman free was not just a
competitor but eight threats a threat to
the entire world of crypto so as soon as
CZ saw the opportunity to pounce he
showed Sam no mercy after CZ was done
with them Sam bakeware free went from a
god-like figure in the crypto world to a
vilified villain literally overnights
stay dangerous and let's get into it
[Music]
FTX is done but even prior to this
historic crash crypto was having a
brutal year losing around two-thirds of
his Peak value and it's not just crypto
either it's brought even the classic 60
40 portfolio of stocks and bonds to its
nice this go-to strategy for decades has
lost 34 its worst performance in 100
years as a result institutions like
Goldman Sachs say portfolios need to be
rebalanced to avoid further losses they
highlight real assets because real
assets have outperformed in volatile
conditions like these in the past like
fine art for example which Goldman
specifically says can protect your
purchasing power in these conditions in
fact the Paul Allen auction just broke
records fetching over 1.6 billion was 65
of paintings selling over their highest
estimate which is no wonder why
Masterworks is seeing increased demand
that's because Masterworks lets you
invest in multi-million dollar paintings
from Legends like Picasso and these are
not nfts by the way there's an offering
circulars with the SEC for each offering
and you know what during the time it
took me to edit this video Masterworks
sold a painting for an insane 17.8 net
return that brings their last three
sales to 1721 and 33 net returns and
five exits in 2022 alone as a result of
their performance Masterworks actually
has a waitlist right now but you can
click the link below for Priority Access
to their newest offerings so pause the
video and click the link below now
[Music]
subscribe
so your Sam bankman freed and you're no
dum-dum you created the fastest growing
crypto Exchange in the world making you
a 10 billion dollar fortune in just
three years in crypto but you know
trouble is on the horizon being a
billionaire puts a Target on your back
and you know that the American
government hates crypto and what it
represents so it's only a matter of time
before they start slapping on
regulations taxes and oversight onto the
crypto industry it's inevitable so you
have two options one you could get all
angry and shake your fist in the air
screaming about how the government can't
just regulate crypto and then inevitably
end up taking it up your butt once the
government does force their way in or
you could accept the reality of the
situation except that Regulators are
coming no matter if you like it or not
and get ahead of the curb so you step
into the spotlight and say that yes
crypto does need more regulation we do
need the government to step in and
protect investors that crypto is far too
powerful too important to not regulate
it and that conveniently I am here as
your humble servant to answer any
questions Regulators or congress members
may have about how to regulate crypto
while little does everyone know that
you're the greedy business you're saying
to protect the public from that while
you're advising regulators and how to
Corral in the industry you suddenly
sneak in regulations that favor you
while crushing your competitors that
even though you can afford all the
lawyers and fees that these regulations
require to navigate
newcomers looking to get in on the
industry can't in other words instead of
fighting against regulations instead of
fighting competitors why not create the
regulations in your favor and let the
government crush your competitors for
you that's exactly what Jeff Bezos of
Amazon was doing back in 2018. back then
Amazon was getting a lot of bad press
over their work conditions so Bezos
announced Amazon would be raising its
minimum wage to at least 15 an hour
how Noble he supports the Working Man
but immediately after that Amazon also
announced it would officially start
lobbying Congress to increase the
federal minimum wage as well for workers
rights of course on the outside it looks
self-sacrificing Bezos is putting his
own money on the line to get Workers
paid more but if you read between the
lines you'll realize that by doing so
all of his competitors are forced to
feel the brunt of his minimum wage
increase as well not just him and that's
exactly what Sam bankman freed was going
for he became a political Mega donor
pumping more than 50 million dollars a
year into American politicians and
campaigns to push for more regulations
kind of regulations that would make it
nearly impossible for competitors like
binance to operate in America at one
point Sam said he planned on spending up
to one billion dollars on politics in
2024. also he could influence the
government to implement some of his
ideas for policing the crypto industry
and not their own in other words he was
planning on legally bribing American
politicians 1 billion dollars to
indirectly hand him a complete Monopoly
over the country's crypto industry again
a very clever yet logical move when
you're a man in his position as you can
imagine Sam's big plans for regulating
crypto quickly turned him and FTX into
Public Enemy Number One in the crypto
World After All crypto came about out of
the desire to be free from the greedy
hands of governments and no one hated
Sam Beekman freed scheming more than CZ
of binance like most Rivals CZ and Sam
started out as friends just six months
after Sam launched TX CZ bought a 20
stake in the exchange their partnership
was supposed to turn them into the
crypto exchange dream team but then in
2021 things quickly went South Sam
suddenly announced he had bought back
all of CZ and binance's shares in FTX
due to quote differences between how we
run our businesses end quote that's
because CZ is the exact opposite of Sam
he believes in keeping crypto free from
censorship free from the hands of
governments he is the ultimate crypto
maximalist in his own words quote I am a
maximalist of freedom and he saw right
through Sam's intentions of getting in
bed with the US government sees he would
later call out salmon a tweet saying
quote we won't support people who Lobby
against other industry players behind
their backs end quote so when crypto
experienced the massive two trillion
dollar crash in May of 2022 CZ saw his
opportunity to take out his Nemesis for
good
[Music]
when crypto crashed in May 2022 FTX was
in a pretty good position it was growing
faster than any other exchange out there
and it was valued at over 32 billion
dollars Sam bankman freed even bailed
out other crypto companies that were
going under like blockfi and Voyager in
order to stop the collapse from
spreading like a virus very similar to
what JP Morgan did when he bailed out
other banks in the great financial crash
of 1907. so how did FTX go from bailing
out other crypto exchanges in May to
needing a bailout itself in November
here's what most people assume happened
this is all a theory by the way we don't
know what actually happened yet the
first thing to understand is there are
three main characters in this story Sam
bankman free FTX and his trading firm
called Alameda research Sam is the CEO
of FTX and used to be in charge of
Alameda research as well but even after
Sam left FTX and Alameda research have
stayed very close and connected so close
that salmon alameda's CEO Caroline
Ellison actually dated and lived with
Sam in a luxury Penthouse in the Bahamas
along with eight other FTX and Alameda
execs so for all intents and purposes
Sam Bateman freed FTX and Alameda
research are one and the same and right
up to November 1st things were going
pretty well for Alameda and FTX and then
the leak happened
on November 2nd 2022 coindesk leaked
information showing that a huge chunk of
the 14.6 billion dollars allowed me to
research had on hand was actually made
up of a crypto token created by FTX
called ftt
ftt's ftx's own token that gives its
holders perks what discounted trading
fees on the FTX exchange out of that
14.6 billion dollars around 8 billion
dollars of that was an ftt tokens that
was a big problem because the market cap
of ftt at that time was nowhere near
that at around 3 billion dollars that
meant that Alameda research was
allegedly pretending that they had eight
billion dollars in ftt tokens when the
entire value of every ftt token in
existence was around just three billion
dollars this was scary again you gotta
remember that Alameda research and FTX
are both practically controlled by Sam
Alameda researchers money is practically
ftx's money so if Alameda research was
allegedly lying that much about how much
money they did have how much was FTX
lying about if users on FTX wanted to
let's say withdraw all their money from
FTX at the same time even if FTX sold
all their ftt tokens to pay back users
there might not be enough money to go
around
so people who had money in FTX started
freaking out luckily our guy CZ of
binance had the perfect Ace up his sleep
to take advantage of this crisis see
when CZ and Sam parted Ways part of the
two billion dollars Sam gave CZ for who
shares in FTX was paid in ftt tokens and
CZ would use those ftt tokens for the
kill shot
foreign
[Music]
on November 6th CZ announced that
binance would be liquidating all its ftt
tokens quote due to recent Revelations
that have come to light end quote
basically the biggest crypto Exchange in
the world said we don't trust FTX and
we're gonna single-handedly crash the
price of ftt tokens and that's when
complete chaos and panic set in people
started freaking out and demanding an
explanation so all of me to research in
FTX came out to assure everyone they
were fine and could buy up all the ftt
tokens binance was selling but no one
believed them not with the May crypto
crash so fresh in everyone's memories
suddenly everyone was scrambling to get
their money out of FTX they withdrew
around 6 billion dollars from FTX in
just three days it was the 21st Century
Bank Run and within those same three
days the value of ftt fell from 22 to
less than three dollars a token and
that's when FTS ran out of money to pay
their customers back see the company may
have looked like it had a whole lot of
assets that could be liquidated to pay
for withdrawals but when a big part of
your assets are actually just your own
tokens that just crashed in price you
are screwed the SEC launches a probe to
investigate whether Sam violated
Securities rules making Sam's clever
plan to lobby for more regulations
really come full circle
easy had Sam right where he wanted him
just days after cz's announcement that
binance was getting rid of its ftt
tokens Sam bankman freed was facing the
possibility of 94 of his entire
estimated 15 billion dollar net worth
being wiped out the only way Sam could
even Hope to come out of the disaster in
one piece would be to find emergency
funds so he can give his customers their
money back they needed a bailout if he
didn't FTX was gonna collapse entirely
but who would have billions of dollars
on hand to give to a failing crypto
exchange with no other options and no
way out Sam had no choice he would have
to come crawling back to none other than
CZ
thank you
on November 8th CZ tweeted that FTX
asked for binance's help funding all
their customers withdrawals in response
binance agreed to sign a non-binding
letter of attempt to buy FTX and bail
them out basically binance was saying if
everything on FTX is side checked out
they would probably buy the entire
exchange and save it from destruction
now Sam binkman Freed's fate laid in the
hands of the one guy that started it all
oh how the tables had turned
for a split second it looked like
binance and CZ were really gonna follow
through and save FTX from impending doom
but then again why would they binance
was already the biggest crypto exchange
on the Block FTX its main competitor was
busy sinking and now here was his
greatest rival on his knees weak and
begging for mercy so what did CZ do he
took the kill shot just one day after
announcing that they might buy FTX CZ
backed out as a result of corporate due
diligence binance would no longer be
moving forward with the deal
Sam's fate was sealed in the end all Sam
can really say about what happened was
I'm sorry and I've hooked up along with
a cryptic message quote well played you
won end quote referring to a quote
particular sparring partner end quote on
November 11th just four days after
telling everyone FTX was fine The
Exchange filed for bankruptcy and Sam
bankman freed announced he would be
stepping down as CEO and the man that
took over the position as CEO is a man
named John J Ray III John J Ray III
happens to be the man that oversaw the
liquidation of Enron after they
collapsed and as we were editing this
video it came out that FTX had been
hacked and that Sam bankman freed built
a back door in his company's accounting
software to move billions of customers
dollars without raising suspicion
almost two billion dollars of customers
money is now missing rumors started
flying around that salmon taken the
money boarded a private jet and escaped
to Argentina but Sam denied those rumors
telling Reuters that he is still in the
Bahamas FTX says they're now working
with law enforcement and that they're
shutting down trading and withdrawals
this story just keeps getting juicier so
make sure you subscribe to find out what
happens next
[Music]
there is blood in the streets for the
crypto world right now but even though
cryptocurrencies are experiencing all
this chaos right now the underlying
blockchain technology is still very real
it's very valuable it's already changing
the way many Industries operate and it's
definitely here to stay as the former
CEO of IBM Junior many said quote
blockchain will do for trusted
transactions what the internet did for
information and
what happened to FTX was one of the
risks China cited when it banned
cryptocurrency trading way back in 2021.
apparently the financial crime and
economic instability it could cause was
just too dangerous and potentially
harmful to Chinese citizens which sounds
a little Rich coming from a country that
forcibly harvests its own citizens
organs for money yes you heard that
right forced organ harvesting where the
Chinese military and hospitals pretty
much kill and harvest the organs of
political prisoners at will why money
obviously we're talking 62 000 for a
kidney thirty thousand dollars for an
eye one hundred twenty thousand dollars
for a liver three hundred thousand
dollars for a pair of lungs
the organ harvesting business in China
has turned into a multi-billion dollar
industry that traces its roots back all
the way to the 1970s but obviously
diving into the Gory details of how
China's little side business got started
would be way too graphic for a public
video so instead we've released it as a
private documentary only available to
members of this Channel and just FYI
this is probably our most disturbing
private documentary yet all you have to
do to watch it is pause the video scroll
down and click that join button below
this YouTube membership is where we get
to post documentaries every month that
we've always wanted to make but never
could and members love them and there's
a 30-day refund policy too if it's your
first time joining so you have nothing
to lose and members rarely request a
refund anyways because it's just that
worth it pause the video scroll down and
click that join button now
I don't know about you guys but I love
learning about the story super smart
moves from both CZ and Sam obviously CZ
came out on top but I respect the game
if you're new here this is one of the
biggest channels on YouTube for
documentaries on money power war and
crime so if you enjoyed this video click
that subscribe button below but yeah
that is going to wrap it up stay
dangerous out there and I will see you
guys in the next one
thank you
[Music]